rights well now to California where
Governor Gavin Newsom he is doubling
down on his threats of legal charges
after Florida Governor Ron DeSantis sent
two migrant flights to Sacramento
Florida officials have confirmed
desantis's involvement with the flights
and Newsome alleges that those migrants
were forcefully relocated without
consent bogus Newsom telling Politico
quote we are very serious about pursuing
action if the facts dictated and Mr
DeSantis should know that but desantis's
team is now pushing back against
newsom's claim and releasing this new
video of migrants signing consent forms
before boarding the chartered flights
look at that another new footage footage
that shows some appearing to enjoy
themselves during the trip is that a
party bus kind of looks like that is and
they're fist bumping yeah
the new video also shows migrants happy
to be in California and saying they were
treated well watch
ES
Kennedy I've not seen many kidnappings
that involve party buses and thank you I
mean when Emily Cabana was in charge of
the activity weekend oh then maybe
I thought I saw Kennedy and Emily on one
of those party buses and there was a
poll in the middle oh my gosh I don't
know you need directions hanging out
with a flagpole with U.S flags but I I
will say this like Gavin Newsom seems
very angry he should be delighted that's
a sanctuary State he's the governor of
the largest Sanctuary state in the
country and he should have sent Governor
DeSantis a fruit basket and a
handwritten thank you note because all
of these people are very eager to go
participate in the California Dream
unfortunately when they land they're
going to see rampant homelessness and
exorbitant taxes when they try and pay
for anything so I don't know why
Governor Newsom is upset about this he
should really be welcoming all of his
new California friends he should be and
let's talk a moment about consensual
kidnapping how that works in the law
Emily uh Sacramento Bee saying
kidnapping charges for DeSantis newsom's
threat over migrant flights or a ploy
and there's this quote it stuck out to
me because it's UC Berkeley yeah so you
know a big lib place this is a professor
there's an irony to the fact that these
criminal justice progressives who get
elected on a Criminal Justice Reform
agenda are now trying to use criminal
law and pretty expansive and creative
ways to forward their political agenda
interesting so bogus charges yeah
Professor Roth was right on the money
there so essentially we knew this was a
political ploy to begin with we knew
this was another tactic for attention
grabbing that Governor Newsom loves to
embroil himself in but the fact remains
that for someone that that sanctions not
Prosecuting anything above 900 that has
let his State Fall to Absolute ruin
because of the lack of Law and Order
there for him to wield this for him to
cite this as an actual tactic and Tool
against another sitting Governor while
ignoring completely the floodgates that
deeply and detronously impact all of The
Californians under his wife watch it's
just a joke and that's the problem with
this is that while the rest of us
Americans are dealing with putting food
on the table and and buying our kids
school supplies we're trying to figure
out how the resources in our communities
go effectively toward us they are
behaving on stage as if it's one big
audition for the White House govern how
about how about govern get off the TV
get off the Billboards in Florida get
off your sound bites and govern I want
to see less fatalities from fentanyl
less fatalities from Criminal violence
from homelessness the list goes on how
about that Governor Newsom start there
well DeSantis is meeting with border
sheriffs in Arizona and your Governor
you must be proud of him Ken do you want
to take ownership I think something
about that you know hair gel or
something has gotten into uh his brain
because I couldn't agree more with Emily
I think Newsom his outrage at this the
kidnapping is just ridiculous we're the
Welcome State come on in welcome what
happened all of a sudden the doormat's
been taken away and I also feel like
heat should be more concerned with many
friends of mine that have moved to our
area from San Francisco because they say
their kids get off the school bus and
have to step over people that are on the
the street corners and there's needles
all around Newsome needs to worry about
his own backyard and not Governor de
Santa and you know Florida government
there noting Texas to send 14 000
migrants Arizona three thousand and this
is what was interesting to me Chicago
Lori Lightfoot The disgraced mayor who
failed to win a re-election sent 100
alone to one suburb DeSantis has sent
50. and I actually think I figured out
Gavin Newsom here here's what's going on
he thinks my taxes are so high they're
not going to agree to go from that bus
to a homeless encampment there's no
housing here they're going to end up at
the governor's mansion outside my place
and I don't want them there and by the
way the whole idea here is that he
doesn't care about red stage does he
doesn't care about Texas or Florida at
all and I talked to Robert Redfield this
morning CD former CDC director who you
know well he said the whole purp he's a
great guy the whole purpose of title 42
wasn't only about covet it was to
protect the migrants health and by
rescinding it we've had so many
thousands and thousands of people
flooding across the border putting
Public Health at risk overloading
hospitals overloading communities what
are the Border communities supposed to
do by sending people to places like
Gavin's backyard I think they're sending
a message here what about a national
response to this that it that says by
the way for for decades in the United
States history we checked people for
health issues before they came into the
United States that's safe we're not
checking illegal immigrants when they
come in and they're spreading diseases
no and now we want to put them in homes
private residences in New York City wow
interesting what a plan hey everyone I'm
Emily compagno catch me and my co-host
Harris Faulkner and Kaylee mcaneny on
outnumbered every weekday at 12 pm
Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights